I talk about it as sort of like the
difference between comedy and horror is
the music they're not even sisters
they're conjoined twins for me they're
both about truth if you if you're not
accessing something that feels true
you're not doing it right well they're
both about taking an extreme absurdity
and grounding it they're both to me the
best ways I I know of for us to deal
with our fears specifically I mean
really the fear of death they also the
technique of them you have to be very
tuned into the audience and their their
emotion both both forms the the
technique is tension building and
release and it's no mistake to me that
comedy and horror replicate that notion
of pattern pattern pattern and then we
break the pattern and there is a
visceral reaction when we break that
pattern so to me I think it's very I
just think it's very connected